now President Donald Trump's travel ban
on people from seven predominantly
Muslim countries has suffered a new set
back this time a Virginia judge ruling
that it's likely violates the rights of
state residents let's get more and get
over to Rainey inocencia in New York for
that Remy yeah not just the state's
residents not just Virginia's residents
but also its institutions is what this
judge is saying and this potentially
moves it closer one step closer to the
Supreme Court now a little bit more
about this judge her name is Leone bring
keema and this is out of the US eastern
district in Alexandria Virginia she was
appointed by President Bill Clinton
almost a quarter century ago a
democratically nominated judge here 1993
was when she started her commission and
she was actually fundamental in the
initial push back that we saw back on
january twenty eighth with the initial
immigrant band that President Trump did
put out she issued a temporary
restraining order at ero that gave all
permanent legal residents access to
lawyers are about 60 of them over at the
airport there at dulles international
airport she also blocked petitioners
from being removed and does count
herself as one of four judges across the
country who did push back after that
immigrant ban was first rolled out but
the question now reach is whether this
will actually matter or not bottle
people right now in the initial reaction
are saying that it probably won't one
because mr. Trump said that he might
issue a totally new immigration order to
revise a ban and also that pending
appeals it could go to the Supreme Court
wish